the Ebola outbreak has killed two
thousand across West Africa and the wh 0
is warning that 20,000 more could die
Europe has pledged 115 million euros to
country's worst affected but there are
calls to do more the UN is calling for
millions more funding and US President
Barack Obama is set to ramp up US aid
effort by sending a host of medical
professionals d-concord Zeb's is una
carta sofa about deficits naw Kham beard
and haas fella DN a-- knee angle via
valve a Linda Stanton and it is the
center stands dibs on the bottom is Nick
no digas on track system so non non
Smith production took a cancun in order
to flee me amongst Dauphin vision of no
reason lavina ovens to come in order to
stimulate the economy we have to go
digital the Internet can provide a more
open and versatile platform for
innovation and business and give those
with monopolies like Google a run for
their money but some of questions for
the EU commissioners designate tasked
with Europe's digital future there is
some cause for concern for example the
commissioner and sip was in 2012 a
fervent supporter of the
anti-counterfeiting trade agreement that
was really going to hurt internet
freedoms and people all over Europe were
protesting against that so this is
definitely something we're going to
bring up in the questioning of the
commissioners to see if they are
actually willing to now modernize
copyright
the six billion European youth
initiative which aims to help you
countries combat youth unemployment
kicked off at the beginning of this year
and the plenary the council and
Commission will present their thoughts
on how it's going the youth unemployment
initiative the youth guarantee can be a
big part of the solution if there is a
general restart of growth and a new
economic policy of you but with great
stagnating and deflation circling Europe
how much can be put into key programs to
kick-start the economy will have to be
seen